[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing professor
filius Flitwick and the not so subtle
change in his physical appearance that
occurred during the film's first is a
very brief summary on the man himself
professor filius Flitwick was the
resident charms master at Hogwarts and
head of Ravenclaw house he was a half
goblin wizard and a former Zhu Ling
Campion were first introduced to
Flitwick right at the beginning of the
books and films in Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone and we see the same
Flitwick returned in Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets but in the third
film the Prisoner of Azkaban flicks
appearance makes a pitiful 180 the old
bald gray-bearded Flitwick that we had
become accustomed to in the first films
was replaced with something very
different but it wasn't that the actor
had changed it was still Warwick Davis
they just completely reshaped the
character where he was previously
gray-bearded he now sported a brown
mustache curled on the ends and where he
previously had no hair on the top of his
head that would now showed off his full
head of brown hair parted down the
middle his new look made him appear
massively younger which in a way
actually made more sense than the way he
looked previously Flitwick is not a
particularly old character but his
former appearance made him look like he
was giving even Dumbledore around
freshmen in royalty while we don't know
Flip wigs exact age it is widely
speculated that he was born sometime
between 1935 and 1958 I definitely lean
more towards the former however as
despite his new younger appearance he
was still older than 40 which is what he
would have been during the Battle of
Hogwarts if he was born in 58 so what
happened why this change really all this
comes down to is the director and the
directors vision Harry Potter 1 & 2 were
directed by Chris Columbus who had a bit
of a different style than Alfonso cuarón
who took over from him starting with the
Prisoner of Azkaban Warwick Davis who
plays Flitwick
to read about Quran and the change in
his character he had this to say Alfonzo
really wanted to put his mark on the
films and then a lot of things altered
anything from character looks to the
actual layout of Hogwarts itself and
another thing was happening at the same
time there wasn't really anything for
Flitwick in the script at all and I got
a call one day from the producer saying
basically there's nothing for you but
we'd love for you to be in the film all
the same how do you fancy coming in and
doing a kind of cameo in the film as
somebody else and I said well that's
great thanks for asking
I'm always thrilled to be part of all of
this anyway so I went in for a meeting
with our funds of the director and Nic
Doug 'land who's the makeup supervisor
and we came up with this new look for
this character who would be basically
the conductor of the Frog chorus in the
Great Hall and so we went with that it
just so happens that this character the
conductor of the Frog choir ended up
being one in the same with Flitwick so
really this just comes down to directors
preference while it's unusual to
completely change a character after two
films I think the part of the beauty in
the Harry Potter films is how they
evolved my favorite part about them and
the thing that I resonated with most was
that the main characters were my age as
they aged and a new film came out every
couple of years I was always in awe of
the evolution that occurred while the
Philosopher's Stone in the Chamber of
Secrets were deeply magical and amazing
the style of the film's did need to
evolve for this reason I don't think
that changing flip works appearance so
drastically was much of a problem for me
one thing worth mentioning however is
that Rowling herself was not much of a
fan of Flip Wix appearance in the first
two films in an interview she had this
to say I must admit I was taken aback
when I saw the film Flitwick who looks
very much like a goblin or elf because
the flip book in my imagination simply
looks like a very small old man I think
that the Flitwick that quran created was
much more suited to Rowling's original
idea for the character what do you guys
think of the flip book switch that
occurred between the second and third
films did you prefer a particular
version of Flitwick let me know down in
the comments section below
and that's all for this video if you
enjoyed it please hit the like
button until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]